[Music]
in split James played I think on camera
he played nine the characters and we
referenced the 23 characters on the
computer screen and four glass
we fleshed out every single character
and this 24 with the Beast
so we fleshed out every single one we
shot every single one and not all of
them made it into the movie but 20 did
so he does 20 personalities in glass
which is I mean astonishing I was trying
so hard to get all 23 in my but I
couldn't do it I think we see 20 in this
film any particular one that you can
give us a preview of or that you're
excited for the ball to meet there's one
character actually who I loved who come
every his name no it's been a while
sorry guys he's only in a flick to
settings but he he sees the world from a
third-person and as a fetus in the
racing in the third person and and
that's how he makes sense of the world
and I loved just exploding that for a
little second you know it's overwhelming
to be on set and have these world-class
actors who are so the iconic and cinema
come and play these characters but
because I'm the writer director I
there's a very specific thing I'm trying
to get am and I always talked to them in
terms of that character I never talked
to them and hey you know in
hypotheticals we're talking about Elijah
we're talking about Kevin or Patricia or
David and I'm saying David thinks like
this I don't think he would go because
David would feel like that the way you
did that performance made David too
angry whatever however we always thought
talked to they could protect protect the
character is well all we're coming from
him we're all conjuring this thing to
life you know the actors and I and I and
I take that process very seriously and
they take it very seriously I've been
watching Bruce Willis since moonlighting
you know and just like he's been on my
TV in my fears for all that time be in
this just hero this total icon you know
as to getting to work with that and that
kind of
that's of that iconic statuesque quality
here's what it's that he does so let on
it's just so powerful it was amazing to
be around then marry that with the kind
of mayhem that I'm doing and all the
kind of like cartwheels and backflips
know that kind of stuff and then on the
other side of that you've got Samuel
Jackson just kneeling everything with a
kind of pinpoint precision and variable
dexterity which is amazing to be around
and then top of that you could set a
pulse and who's got this amazingly sort
of emotional expressive vulnerability
throughout the whole thing and you know
she's got she's potentially the
antagonist and she's got and she's
playing out with vulnerability so you so
much interesting work and so much
different work coming from the four
actors that are in those therapy scenes
that are in those moments is amazing to
be part of that it's a privilege to be
afar that you've added another element
to this film Sarah Paulsen's character
doctor at least a fool what does she
bring to this sort of interesting power
and character dynamic yeah you know I
wanted to make sure that in each movie
there was a powerful new language a
powerful new element in it and in glass
the new element is sarah paulson so I
was thinking about who could be the
psychiatrist who could spar with these
guys who could challenge these guys both
his actors but on camera the energy the
the kind of buoyancy and entertainment
value the intelligence the craft that
she could challenge and challenge them
and because for me my action sequences
in my comic book movie are the dialogue
scenes they're kind of like the sizzle
of how they're fighting each other and
so who could who could battle them off
and I felt like Sarah was the perfect
person to lock her in the room with and
see if Sam could out talk her or he
could she could out think you know Bruce
or you know all of those things that as
the duels go on between them all and she
could show the compassion of meeting all
the different personalities and try to
help these guys dr. le staple is the
newest addition to
this universe and I feel incredibly
honored to be part of it because I don't
know if you know but sort of an iconic
universe - all of a sudden find yourself
involved with I play a psychiatrist who
specializes in studying those
individuals who believe they are either
superhuman or super heroes and and
particularly dealing with the idea of
delusion of grandeur working with night
was really extraordinary mostly because
it felt like being with a member of my
own family
simply because and by my own family I
mean me I'm an incredibly controlling
exacting kind of person by nature and to
me it's all in the details and I really
love that kind of way of working and so
for me it was very relaxing actually to
be working with someone who had
something so specific in mind that it
wasn't up to me to come up with three
different ways to play the scene Knight
knew exactly how he wanted and what he
needed and what he was going to be
shooting I remember shooting a scene one
day where I was delivering a piece of
information to to another character and
it was a long speech and he shot it
starting on my face and then hinged the
camera over to the person I was speaking
to and then stayed with that character
the entire time and I kept thinking like
dude this is big speech that I have and
I think you should be right here and I
asked him what what was the thinking and
he said the audience is going to care
they are going to want to see the person
to whom you're delivering this
information what their responses the
information you're giving to them they
want to see how it affects this person I
thought Knight knows exactly what the
audience wants and he it's all
purposeful he's not nothing you see up
theirs by happenstance it's it's really
really premeditated and and carefully
carefully thought-out from a story
perspective and so I have nothing but
respect for that so when we got him he
was fresh off of you know the success of
you know I see dead people and all of a
sudden you know
got a little nicked with this movie but
this movie has an enduring kind of cult
following that's amazing but you know he
got banged around between those movies
and split and it's one of those things
that you either learn from or you keep
trying to impose your will on something
that's just not gonna Bend to you and I
think he's learned how to nuance what he
does with what is sort of popular in
terms of what storytelling actually is
what was it like to return to the
character of Elijah for this wondrous
for me to have a guy 14 years later
who's kind of you know everybody thinks
one thing is going on with him but you
know he has his own agenda as usual
he's been quietly studying plotting
planning paying attention to the world
outside in an interesting way so that he
knows what you know David is doing he
knows who mr. Krum is so when they show
up he has a very good idea of what he
wants to do with these guys and Elijah
is as sharp as he's always been yeah
I've been having fun playing with the
people in inside that place he's not
gonna meet his match in this film I
don't think so
there are a lot of different things you
know we could talk about that would
jeopardize whatever's going on in film
but he's he's still the sharpest knife
in the drawer what is the official title
for this universe or series I've seen
some people say it's the east rail 177
series what do you what do you call it
you know I I definitely have heard
people call it that the east rail 177
series which is really cool I think very
interesting and
granular in a beautiful way and when
they when you see all three it even
makes mmm it's more appropriate oh
that's all outside so that's a really
beautiful idea of it I I don't know
because I really wanted them to be
stand-alones that are also you know
commenting on each other but that you
could watch each of them by themselves
so if they each have their distinct own
[Music]
you